the story is set in the winter of 1982 a
remarkable Discovery unfolds as members
of the Norwegian research station Thule
stumble upon another worldly spacecraft
buried beneath the icy Antarctic surface
this Expedition is joined by the
American paleontologist Kate Lloyd Dr
sander Halverson and his assistant Adam
Finch excitement fills the air as they
set upon a helicopter Journey alongside
skilled pilot Sam Carter and Derek
Jamison accompanied by crewman Griggs
upon their arrival at Thule they're
greeted by station Chief Edvard walner
and his dedicated team including Juliet
Carl olav Jonas Colin Henrik Peter Lars
and even lars's loyal Canine Companion
together they delve into the mystery
surrounding the Unearthed alien craft in
the nearby body as the intense
excavation continues the otherworldly
body encased within a solid block of ice
is carefully retrieved and brought back
to the Thule station during a moment of
Celebration a startling Revelation
unfolds when Jameson Bears witness to
the astonishing site of the alien
bursting free from its icy prison in a
Race Against Time the team mobilizes in
search of The elusive creature only to
be confronted by a heart-wrenching
discovery which is that lars's faithful
Canine Companion lies lifeless a grim
Testament to the alien's deadly presence
horror strikes as the alien seizes
Henrik engulfing him in a terrifying
display of violence and leaving olav
drenched in a Macabre spray of blood
faced with the imminent threat the group
musters all their courage and
resourcefulness taking decisive action
to eradicate the creature that now poses
a grave danger to their very survival
through a strategic maneuver they ignite
spilled fuel unleashing a blazing
Inferno that consumes the alien putting
an end to its Menace however the
aftermath brings about a chilling
Revelation during the subsequent autopsy
which is that the alien cells were
actively replicating henrik's own
hinting at a Sinister assimilation
process as the team grapples with the
implications of this horrifying
Revelation olav too falls into a
mysterious illness adding a new layer of
urgency and uncertainty to their already
dire circumstances as the chaos and
danger escalate a chilling
transformation unfolds within the team
as Carter Jameson and Griggs take flight
in the helicopter intending to transport
the already suffering Olaf to a medical
facility an inconceivable transformation
takes place Griggs undergoes a grotesque
and monstrous change viciously attacking
Olaf leading to a catastrophic
helicopter crash into the unforgiving
mountains in the middle of the wreckage
Kate stumbles upon a gruesome sight a
shower tainted with blood and dental
fillings a startling realization Dawns
upon her as she confronts the Grim truth
the alien entity possesses the ability
to assimilate and replicate its victims
disguising itself within their very
ranks now lurking among them it poses an
Insidious threat camouflaged and ready
to strike as tensions Run High Edvard
the station Chief orders the team to
make a desperate drive to the nearest
base seeking safety and a means of
Escape however not all members of the
team are in agreement both Juliet and
Kate acutely aware of the danger they
face are determined to prevent anyone
from leaving understanding the necessity
of containing the threat within the
confines of the station in a Sinister
turn of events Juliet cunningly lures
Kate into an abandoned room her true
nature revealed as she transforms into a
terrifying entity launching a vicious
attack however Kate manages to narrowly
escape leaving behind a trail of chaos
and Carnage The Juliet thing claims Carl
as its victim but Lars valiantly wields
a flamethrower extinguishing the
abomination in a blaze of fire with
their resolve hardened and the threat
undeniable the remaining team members
make a collective decision to quarantine
themselves barricading against the
Insidious presence lurking within their
midst bound together by a shared purpose
they prepare to confront the alien
menace head-on determined to eliminate
the threat and restore safety to their
isolated Outpost as the night descends
upon the embattled survivors a sense of
Suspicion and uncertainty permeates the
air Carter and Jameson miraculously
returning from the wreckage of the
downed helicopter find themselves met
with weary gazes and a collective doubt
regarding their true nature fearing that
they may have fallen victim to the
alien's Insidious assimilation the duo
is promptly imprisoned in a state of
isolation seeking a means to unmask the
hidden enemy within the their ranks Kate
puts forth a daring proposal recognizing
the alien's inability to replicate
inorganic material she suggests a
thorough examination of each
individual's Dental fillings it is a
grim but necessary measure one that may
expose the true identities of the alien
imposters lurking among them the dental
filling test commences and a startling
Revelation follows sander Edvard Adam
and Colin the very individuals devoid of
any Dental fillings find themselves
implicated by the examination everyone
becomes suspicious of them as the weight
of Doubt threatened their existence the
survivors now stand at a Crossroads
forced to confront the terrifying
reality that their own trusted comrades
may have succumbed to the alien's
malevolent influence with their lives
hanging in the balance they must
navigate the treacherous path ahead
making difficult decisions in the
pursuit of self-preservation and the
eradication of the Hidden threat
paranoia among the people increases as a
devastating turn of events shatters The
Fragile sense of security that remains
Lars while on a mission to retrieve
Carter and Jameson for testing Falls
victim to a chilling abduction in a
desperate bid to uncover the truth and
regain control Carter and Jameson take
matters into their own hands breaking
into the main building they confront the
unsuspecting painter a Fateful Encounter
unfolds culminating in a deadly
confrontation that claims Peter's life
as destruction and Chaos engulfs the
scene a flamethrower tank is punctured
igniting a devastating explosion that
leaves Edvard unconscious the survivors
are thrust into a treacherous situation
their lives teetering on the edge of
Oblivion with the main room as their
Battleground a tense confrontation
ensues as Edvard violently undergoes a
grotesque transformation infecting both
Jonas and Jameson rendering them mere
vessels for the aliens Insidious
assimilation in the face of unspeakable
horror Kate musters her resolve and
unleashes the cleansing power of fire
she Burns Jonas and Jameson their
transformation halted before it reaches
its full horrific potential in this
desperate struggle for survival Kate and
Carter Stan as the last line of defense
against the Relentless thing that seeks
to assimilate and Conquer driven by
sheer determination Kate and Carter
continue on a harrowing Pursuit their
every step fraught with uncertainty the
thing Relentless in its pursuit of
dominance unleashes its wrath
assimilating sander as the darkness
blankets the Frozen landscape the sander
thing speeds into the night relentlessly
pursued by Kate and Carter in a Race
Against Time however their hopes for a
joint Victory are shattered when the
dormant spacecraft abruptly Springs to
life forcefully separating the
determined Duo things take a turn as
Kate finds herself plunged Into the
Heart of the alien vessel face to face
with the monstrous form of sander
drawing upon her resilience she bravely
engages in a life or death struggle
ultimately unleashing a grenade that
shatters the creature and brings the
ship's engines to a halt reuniting with
Carter amidst the aftermath Kate's
suspicions are aroused as she notices
the absence of his earring a Telltale
sign of assimilation by the Insidious
thing with tension thick in the air
Carter's misleading gestures indicate
the wrong ear exposing his true nature
in a swift Act of survival Kate
unleashes cleansing Flames reducing the
Carter thing to ashes and swiftly makes
her way to the second snow cat
determined to leave the nightmare behind
with the dawn of a new day the scene is
set for a chilling Revelation as thule's
helicopter Guided by Pilot Matthias
returns to the desolate ruins horror and
disbelief wash over Matthias as he
beholds the Grim remnants of the station
and the husk of the Edvard Adam thing
amidst The Haunting aftermath the weight
of Despair Bears heavily as they
discover Colin's tragic fate having
chosen to take his own life in the next
scene Lars armed and desperate for
answers holds Matthias at gunpoint
demanding an unsettling request while
showing his teeth just as the gravity of
the situation reaches its peak a glimmer
of unexpected hope emerges lars's dog
previously presumed dead miraculously
re-emerges and makes a swift getaway a
sudden realization Dawns upon the
survivors that the faithful companion
too has fallen victim to the treacherous
thing the movie concludes with the
helicopter pursuit of lars's dog which
is revealed to be a thing an assimilated
organism as the chase ensues the outcome
is left open-ended leaving the fate of
the characters and the ultimate
resolution of the threat posed by the
thing unknown to the audience the movie
ends on a note of suspense and
uncertainty leaving room for
interpretation and speculation click on
one of the two videos on screen right
now